first i want to start by saying congrats
i thought you guys did such a great job
their story
it is so amazing that if you had written
like a screenplay no one would like
people would be like this could never
happen this is absolutely not true for
you guys um when you were researching
and learning about serena and venus and
the story what were some of the things
that you're like this couldn't be true
but it actually is
um how young they were when they started
tennis i mean they started tennis at
four
and five
and uh i mean we both started very young
in our careers as well so something that
something i could relate to for you i
think
i i agree with sanaya but another thing
was the fact that mr richard wrote a
78-page plan
of
the way their career would go and
that's exactly what happened i mean it's
kind of insane it's so crazy how what
actually happened listen i'm obviously a
huge fan of will smith i'm sure you guys
are as well i'm curious
what was your favorite will smith movie
before you made this film and did it
change after working with him
um let me see
there's so many did it change did it
change um um i'm trying to think so
oh man there's so many men in blacks and
then in black so pretty for sure
and then shark two
i love shark tale when i was little i
absolutely love shark tale but oscar the
shark slayer
but other than that one i really really
loved
um i am legend and collab um collateral
beauty so good
yeah as well as pursuit of happiness
that's like all his movies but
pull up imdb let me just start reading
i mean he's such an amazing actor
that i'm i'm i've just fallen in love
with all of his works me too yeah i
think he's so
so great even when he's on fresh prince
like watching each season you can see
how he grew as an actor you know
no 100 and this actually leads me to
what i wanted to ask you guys which is
he is such a talented actor i'm sure
that working with him you were observing
and learning and seeing how he does it
so you can incorporate it into your own
you know work what did you actually uh
what did you learn watching him that
you're like i need to do that i need to
do this and i'm doing that
i i feel like more yeah
there's so much
i don't know maybe just
communicating
without our names like he didn't call us
tsunaya and demi caught his venus in
serena
uh so you know it was just staying in
that like family mindset i think is
important you know when you're on set
it's real so it was real for us and i
loved watching him create um even more
of a relationship with us each day
um
i think similar to what's nice that how
in character he was all the time even
during our lunch break he was still
richard williams you know he never broke
character not until
our director called cut for the last
time you know and so
i really admired that how even during
his breaks and during his rest time he
was still
his character yeah
it carries over into his performance i
gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
congrats on making it through the day of
press and congrats on the movie and go
get some food and enjoy your night thank
you so much for talking it was a
pleasure thank you
you